bringing howard back let's say those
howard still with this bleacher report
NBA senior writer good morning howard
how are you french so i hope you can
translate the english for the rest of us
alright well we'll try to stay away from
z on right now but given what you wrote
in your column NBA exec skeptical lakers
can build a title team after anthony
davis overpay did they overpay in your
opinion um this is a tricky thing what i
wrote was one that's trade but they lost
the negotiation and what i mean is if
you get the best player and they did you
didn't find you won like look you've got
anthony davis in your pairing with
lebron james i don't want to overthink
it but they lost the negotiation Dan
because the New Orleans pelicans were
the ones over a barrel here Anthony
Davis wanted out Anthony Davis wanted to
be in LA Anthony Davis was on an
expiring deal and the pelicans were in a
tough spot similar to how the Spurs were
with Kawhi Leonard a year ago similar to
you know Kyrie a couple years ago except
that he would had two years left the
pelicans should not have had much
leverage but what they got was the
Lakers two best young players and please
I don't want to hear anybody tell me
that Kyle Kuzma is better than Lonzo
ball and Brandon Ingram they got their
two best young players they got picks
they got the pick swap they got the take
that could be either 2024 or 2025 the
pelicans now have control of most of the
Lakers draft through for the next six
years and they got of course number four
tonight that's a lot to pay when the guy
wanted to come to you anyway and when
the team that he want was going to leave
had to offload him and by the way had no
other great offers because Boston
essentially bowed out the Knicks had
nothing really to offer who else were
they bidding against except themselves
and yeah they lost the negotiation but
they got Anthony Davis well let me go
back to what you said where the pelicans
got their two best players do you you
don't think that Kyle Kuzma is better
than Lonzo ball or Brandon Ingram
or not even close Kyle Cruz was a really
solid player who I think Laker fans in
particular have elevated into
hall-of-famer he's he's a really good
player and he's a modern player he's got
all that that lettuces Amman lengthen
switchability and he's good in the open
court and you know lucky he's a fine
player he may even become a very very
good player and he might actually end up
with a better career than the other two
like that that's on the table but come
on Alonzo ball and Brandon Ingram are 21
years old each they were the number two
overall pick each be for reasons
Mazal ball is already a supreme defender
and the lawns of all drew Holiday
backcourt could be just ferocious
defensively we know lawns does it gifted
passer we know that he has one of the
funkiest jump shots we've ever seen and
then that is going to have to get fixed
someday but it's too soon to say well
he's injured and so let's give up on him
and Brandon Ingram well he's been a
little bit up and down for two years
that's how it goes for young guys in
this league and you still bet on the
upside and every other GM in this league
would be betting on that upside I like
Lonzo a lot you know I'm not a fan of
his father's I think if he didn't have
his father you know circling hovering we
would look at Lonzo ball a little
differently but I you know the jumper is
a big concern there and I don't know if
it's fixable because I'm amazed and I
mentioned this you know that as great as
lebar ball tells as he is as a coach he
couldn't help his son come up with a
decent jumper and I don't know how you
fix that now if your New Orleans I got
to have you at least be respectable and
somewhat dangerous or gar noble at the
3-point line and Lonzo is not that so
how do you fix what has been unfixable
so far great question and sometimes it
just takes the right coach and at the
right time the pelicans do have I think
he's still on staff Mike Penberthy
former three-point specialist for the
Lakers way back during my time covering
them in Penberthy is a very good
shooting coach he's you know worked with
a number of guys in New Orleans he
worked with Ricky Rubio previously and I
know Rubio has been up and down
but to the extent that Rubio has
improved in recent years a lot of that
started when Rubio is working with
Penberthy in Minnesota remember he was
working there so you you and you listen
you you you it you hopefully are
catching if you're the pelicans you're
hopefully catching Alonso at a time when
he's ready to embrace that part of it
where this is a second stage of his
career now the Laker years were you
meant one thing okay new environment new
coach new expectations and you know it's
it's sometimes that you just need to
click to that different gear and we see
guys add things to their game over the
course of their first five to ten years
in the league and sometimes they just
weren't ready to use things on day one
that they're ready to do in year three
so but we prejudge we put these guys in
a box and we say well this is just who
he is you can't shoot okay well you
can't right now it doesn't mean it's
it's forever broken we'll see and you
know III think that ball and Ingram is a
pretty nice return in addition to all
those picks given where the pelicans
were with the Anthony Davis situation
and I think Lonzo out of LA is going to
help him considerably get away from his
dad and be able to just play basketball
I think that he'll be a great teammate
for everybody else in that lineup and I
love the backcourt there you know and I
hope that Ingram is healthy because Zion
is contagious he's infectious with that
personality and wanting others to
succeed and I think they have a chance
to have something really fun there but
also with that number four pick overall
what do you think the pelicans are going
to do with that pick they got from the
Lakers I really am curious to see that
myself I suspect that they will be
flipping it maybe not immediately but
eventually there's too much noise not to
believe that there's been speculation
that they might even try to jump up to
number two and steal our Jay Barrett
from under the Knicks nose Barrett and
Zion obviously close and maybe that
would be a nice you know comfort zone
for Zion debt to have you know here's
what I'm more curious about Dan big
picture what is David Griffin planning
here because you've got Zion who is a
very exciting young player he's not
going to win you games by himself in
year one or maybe
even year two that's the history of the
league you know reuse does not generally
win but drew holiday is an excellent
point guard ordered excellent guard
period whether you play on the ball off
the ball and so are you if you're going
to a full rebuild I would get value for
Drew holiday and flip him but if you're
actually what you're looking to do is
build a winning team right now around
Zion and not have him to have to go
through that usual struggle of the first
three years where you're the only guy
carrying it all and you've got all these
expectations and young guys around you
you could build a veteran a more veteran
team or a blend of veterans and youth
and it's what they kind of have right
now so if you're holding on to Drew and
if you're holding on to Lonzo and
Ingraham and not not immediately turning
around and flipping them and again I
don't know what the intent is there do
you want to flip that number four pick
to get veteran help are you flipping it
for other rookies I'm just I'm more
curious about what the big picture goal
is you're are you trying to win right
away and keep this team relevant and
exciting because it's a tough market or
are you going to look for more of a slow
build and that's that's the real
question I think for the pelicans he's
Howard back of bleacher report and his
latest column NBA execs skeptical Lakers
can build a title team after Anthony
Davis overpay Howard you end your column
this way but the Lakers are living for
today for the thrill of James Davis
alley-oops and the promise of another
Finals run or three James made the
Lakers relative relevant again Davis
makes them legit it'll take much more to
make them champions what do they need
players the rest of our roster they've
got they've really got three players you
know LeBron Anthony Davis which is a
pretty nice start
and Kyle Kuzma but look you need
shooters you need two fenders you need
you know bigs who can rebound and
protect the rim and you just you need a
roster what Toronto just showed us is
that it you know as I also wrote it
takes a village and I think I might have
stolen that line from somebody else um
but you you need you need role guys high
level role guys high level veteran roll
guys and LeBron knows that better than
anyone because he's the guy with eight
straight finals and he's one champion
chips so where are you gonna find your
shane battier Xandra chard lewis's and
Ray Allen's where are you going to find
you know you're hesitating say your
junior Smith's gotta have some yeah so
you've got it you've got to have a
supporting cast that function you can't
just say well you know what buy one more
max guy if you can get to the room and
it is filled out with minimums that's a
really tough road to go and what this
team needs is maybe you know a Danny
Green a Marcus Morris you know both of
them are free agents a Patrick Beverley
maybe a Taj Gibson those are the guys
you need and you can't just assume
you're in a shop in the bargain basement
and get a bunch of minimums those guys
are going to command you know decent
mid-range salaries so I think whether
they've got 23 million under the current
scenario whether they get to 32 million
if they can rework this and get the
timing right whatever the number is I
think you spread it around three four
maybe five players and and and get that
rest of that cast because you're gonna
need I mean like I say it's everything
they need everything except for the two
forward spots or alternatively you know
maybe Anthony Davis is playing small
ball Center and LeBrons before whatever
it is you have a lot of openings on that
roster and you also have you have to
build in time for this roster to kind of
mesh we've seen this with teams before
it happened with the heat when the
LeBron went there where you get you know
three stars together and it takes a
little at least half a season sometimes
a full season to get acclimated with
each other of what you do when you do it
how you do it and Plus Anthony Davis is
now gonna be in playing in important
games he's gonna be in the spotlight now
whereas in New Orleans nobody cared what
he was doing on a nightly basis at least
league wise now everybody cares what
he's doing in every single game and I
think just having that media onslaught
they're gonna be interesting if you get
Kemba Walker who has not had this in
Charlotte you come in and it's LeBrons
team you're coming in Los Angeles
expectation levels are through the roof
I also got a factor that in as well
absolutely agree on all counts and you
know Anthony Davis has never been in a
spotlight like this
Anthony Davis is kind of a low-key dude
how is he going to handle that
every day now he has the benefit of
LeBron taking a lot of the burden in the
spotlight and the spokesman role so he
doesn't have to do it all but seriously
there's gonna be 50 people in his locker
after every game after every practice
every shoot around there's going to be
people surrounding him it's it's a like
nothing he has experienced before and I
know he's been an all-star weekend and
all that that's once a year he had never
been deep in the playoffs he's never
been in LA as a focus of that market so
that all matters you're right about the
supporting cast to that it's one thing
to get that supporting cast and to build
it and build it right and we've never
seen Rob palinka do it he's still a
relative rookie can he pull that off
that's the skepticism I'm alluding to in
the column and then if he does yes now
you need time for those guys to gel but
there is no time because LeBrons turning
35 in December and everything is now and
that's always the case with LeBron even
when he was in his prime so imagine just
how it ramped up the pressure and the
expectations are in year one of LeBron
Anthony Davis together with LeBron
coming off the the toughest year of his
career in terms of injury and a
brand-new supporting cast around them
that has to figure it all out a brand
new coaching staff led by Frank Vogel
there's a lot I mean and and they're
going to be they were installed as
championship favorites the second they
got Anthony Davis so you know that
that's a lot of change and adjustment
and figuring out on the fly for a team
that people are expecting you to go to
the finals would you have the Lakers as
the favorites in the e West
oh man
I mean momentarily penciled them in
because the Warriors are broken and the
Rockets are in flames and I just don't
know that I trust any of those other
teams but at the same time they're all
in it I mean you know the Rockets could
pull it together pick up a third guy and
they're off the races the Jazz are
making a great move by getting Mike
Conley they deserve to be in the
conversation for winning the West the
Thunder will make a case to try to
prefer winning the West the Denver
Nuggets of the Portland Trailblazers
like there's going to be some semblance
of parody for once which we have not
seen in a very long time and mostly
because the Warriors are broken
you know the Lakers will be in that mix
as well but there's a you know we just
don't know what they are yet until the
rest that roster spilled out and by the
way what if the Clippers land Kawhi
Leonard you know throw them into the
discussion too so crowded field which
kind of fun Howard thanks for joining us
we appreciate it enjoy the draft always
budge damn thank you that's Howard Beck
bleacher report for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]